[Aplausos]
boa noite
não sei se isso é ser deixado por fim se
é bom ou mau mas é bom eu vou assumir
como sendo bom mas temos um dos seus
primeiros anos dela é e antes de começar
a própria mente naquilo que eu gostava
de passar uma mensagem que estamos da
volvo só deixar com algumas imagens dos
jogos chatos que eu fiz e espero
conseguir mantê-los acordados
- me mantenho me acordar desse tipo sal
se emociona e deixam os irmãos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o campeão está pedindo ilê quilo
assim ela chama show
mas foi a seu olho no começo e que a mãe
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o esforço arroz esportivo sky
eu tô sentimento hoje foi marcelo quem
não vê penta
aquecer
o jec
meus 17 anos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
os pneus
paulo
ela diz que não
não mesmo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e nesse âmbito
[Música]
e pronto a isto foi algumas coisas
algumas das proezas que o que eu tenho
feito ao longo da minha carreira como
para a pista e vai jantar e sinceramente
não vim aqui pra primeiras palavras de
saltos de paraquedas
a mensagem que eu gostava do passado que
é o clube é na escola para pedir uma
queda livre é o céu não é o limite é o
ponto de partida
isto tem a ver com a minha história
pessoal euch não foi fácil nem fácil
prometo naquela altura não foi uma
infância ou vivência de uma forma é
fácil é pra ficar pelo caminho e e
sobretudo estava muito limitado por
algumas crianças que um script atingiram
outras que eu
um outro tempo fui foi entre lisandro e
muito medo era uma criança extremamente
estava é isso limitava a imensa é a
mensagem que eu estava se eu estava nos
dar qualquer coisa aqui assim para além
de contar uma história que estava
processando levassem convosco
qualquer coisa que possa usar a estação
estava a passar é a treva ons que um já
não sei qual foi o valor dos dois jorge
que combino a sua sua apresentação com
aquela história dos seus cuidados que
faltavam ser um quarto cerqueira coragem
e eu acho que esse eu acho que o show
com sávio com chave de ouro porque de
facto o que nós precisamos nossas vidas
para realmente termos mais para
conseguir uns ser mais felizes mas nós
mais mais precisos mais pra ir mais alto
é essa a ter a coragem de nos desafiamos
a nós próprios não quero que sejam as
nossas nossas dificuldades é todos nós
temos medo uso de uma maneira ou de
outra não é fácil
aqui assim confrontado convosco é o medo
de ser a que vai ficar bem na fotografia
anel fotografia como quem diz será que
será que o que eu vou dizer eh eh vai
fazer sentido será que os vai realmente
ajudar de alguma forma porque esse é de
fato um um adjetivo meu eu como como
justiça da infância não foi não foi
fácil estava muito constrangido
eu tenho imensa mesmo exemplo eu prefiro
namorar uma miúda era o carro
sistemáticas e mandavam mandava um
bilhete depois avast vela com medo que
ela ia dizer que não ocorre no brasil já
era muito complicado nem mesmo em minha
segurança e uma baixa autoestima é e em
uma série de crenças dentro de mim não
vão acreditar que eu não era grande
coisa que as pessoas não tenham que está
realmente em mim sobretudo se realmente
só é assim que eu era pra sair pra sair
uma grande parte da minha vida é
tentaram esconder a tentar mostrar um
mário que não era o mário é tentar
apreender será que o que eu achava que
vocês gostariam que eu fosse uma
tentativa de ser aceito na tentativa de
ser amado
na altura isso vou me um fundo do poço
emocional e iraí humano que vai produzir
conhecimento da primeira volta grande na
minha vida em sair um percurso de
descoberta de mim próprio daí o maior
salto que eu poderia ter dado um salto
para dentro de mim próprio e começar a
descobrir não começará a conhecer e se
começar é só ouvir alguns novos ceps que
eu tenho aqui dentro que o limitava o
completamento eu acho que mais nos
limita é e nos impede de voar mais alto
se pode dizer é é é o nosso conjunto
crianças é que nós acreditamos em
relação ao mundo em relação a nós
próprios nos conjuntos crianças de uma
forma geral é e eu medo o medo que
mostrava é eu essa coisa do paraquedismo
eu precisei fazer para a crise por duas
razões uma facto e aumento a era um
elemento com o qual me identificava
imensa
é sempre o suns emprestei meu suado e eu
lembro-me uso é educar os meus pais e
eles tivessem o calor chuva só fizer só
eu minha janela ia sempre aberta
gostava de renovar com o ar na cara
ainda hoje em dia isso acontece é e para
além disso
além dessa identificação com o documento
a área foi uma uma vontade enorme de
mostrar a mim próprio e ao mundo também
que não tinha medo porque eu tenho outra
coisa o xixi
provavelmente vocês têm essa noção eu
cresci com uma mensagem muito grande de
um homem nunca tem mesmo um homem não
chora e sentir menos homem por causa
disso eu lembro de eu lembro de ter medo
de pensar que tenha medo não fossem os
mesmos pensamentos e ficarem achar que
eu era menos homem por causa disso
estamos a falar de uma carga de trabalho
e na estréia da taça em terapia ver um
livro visto felizmente que tem
conseguido fazer
aprendi que tal é terminar mal nenhum em
ter medo e e eu aceitar essas minhas
emoções e os sentimentos de alguma forma
ganha poder para confrontar com elas
possam ter passado e isso te dizer que
tanto eu fui porto na altura me forma de
começar no paraquedismo feira foi
militar era obrigatório serviço militar
e eu pensava já tem que ir pelo menos
uma coisa que vale a pena e que eu me
identifique e fui o primeiro a saltar o
afastamento aterrorizado saltar e
conseguir não podia não fazia não voltar
atrás era muito complicado
isto num contexto militar que usou isso
quer dizer se não isso não era e outra
e hoje em dia dá um prazer enorme poder
partilhar é a experiência da queda livre
porque não só pela experiência em si mas
como como pelo apelo pelo simbolismo que
aquilo que a reta de dar o salto e
confrontar nos com os nossos medos dar o
salto e quando fazemos pois desfrutamos
de uma do mar no momento é justamente in
para é não só eu lembro perfeitamente no
meu primeiro salto depois de ter saltado
de pára-quedas tabela estava pendurado
no aro olhar aquilo daquela vista
fantástica sentir o arroz a um papel ao
ouvir o barulho do avião desaparecer no
horizonte e me sentir greve e ao mesmo
tempo que ele no meio daquilo tudo e ea
sensação de ter conseguido ultrapassar
os meus medos foi absolutamente
fantástico
eu acho que vale a pena isto acho que
acho que vale a pena nós decidirmos ir
mais além
a escola pena desafiaram as nossas
limitações não acredita em e ultrapassar
os limites porque isso pode resultar mal
mas acredita empurrar os limites
preparando melhor aprendendo encontrando
recursos para conseguir chegar mais
longe
estamos a falar num elemento do meu show
eu não faço os álbuns alguma coisa pra
mim hoje em dia já não era já é
complicada uma coisa relativamente
simples mas eu não deixo de me preparar
eu não gosto de ficar acima para que ela
estava bem do brasil está tudo bem nos
conformes forma queria ter a certeza que
vou tirar um avião baixo a porta vai
servir como atirada ao vivo até lá em
baixo à minha espera mas sim mas eu sei
que tenho para quedas que vai funcionar
banho e para além do ter um equipamento
que eu tenho confiança nele
o time teve um treino todo um treino
toda uma preparação prévia que mundo voa
a sentir um confiante o suficiente para
saber que eu posso fazer aquilo com
segurança portanto não é uma loucura é
uma loucura no sentido é uma loucura mas
é uma loucura muito ponderado é muito e
muito
pensava eu acho que nós todos podemos
fazer isso nas nossas vidas de nossas
carreiras na vida de uma forma geral é
há pouco falei você aquela questão do
das crianças que não são entendidas e
nós apanhamos uma maneira ou de outra o
que os nossos pais nos passaram a
primeira mensagem é porque a sociedade
tem aquelas mensagens do homem nunca tem
medo isto daqui do piloto
eu aprendi que aprendem aprende e essas
vozes estão cá dentro
então cá dentro a dizerem-nos essas
mensagens a retirem essas mensagens que
o que eu aprendi foi é decidir e
primeira identificar essas voz o vila se
identificarem quem esta volta da minha
voz do povo é meu pai é destinado a quem
esta voz e e aprende
agora eu sou eu e o que é ser eu a dizer
ser a voz está sentido quer ficar
limitar por isso não eu quero ir mais
além na minha vida ou não eu quero eu
quero atingir objetivos eu quero atingir
sonhos nossa senhora de uma forma ou de
outra porque vão apenas em área e só não
tenham medo sim aranha também da quase
do sonhar porque sonhar era uma coisa
era um sonho
não não é só a visão e mentira garante
que é absolutamente mentira qualquer só
em possa ser materializado pode ser
realizado a cada dia que passa se eu
fizer ação e ele era um passo em frente
para conseguir esse cara um caminho mais
perto do que eu possa ser o meu sonho
meu objetivo é garantir que o estado nós
vamos lá chegar e tivemos em alguns
jogadores que na primeira pessoa
relataram exemplos e flagrantes disso o
próprio também estaria encontrando aqui
algumas histórias para a história da
minha vida que ilustra isso mas acho que
não vale a pena perder por aí eu acho
que a mensagem que quero passar é e é
essa
é a treva nós iremos tomar uma decisão é
nos momentos de decisão que nós
precisamos é nos momentos de decisão são
os elementos cruciais quando eu posso
seguir pac ao emprego e às vezes um som
direção são diferenças exatamente
minúsculas
eu lembro de um exemplo não resolve mas
faz todo sentido assis o jogador de
golfe quando da sua casa basta dar a
tacada um milímetro um lado ao outro
quando a bola chega ao fundo o objetivo
não quero não tá um milímetro lado do
buraco está é metros
às vezes uma piscina um clima justa
da nossa parte na forma como nós damos a
nossa década como nós jogamos o nosso
jogo aqui é um milímetro mas um dia mais
à frente dois dias três dias um ano
cinco anos 10 mil à frente
a diferença é um instinto totalmente
diferente da que eu poderia ter sido nós
não nos não tivesse esse vídeo daquela
casa portanto acredita é nos momentos de
decisão que nossa torcida
dani decidam ir mais longe decidi não ir
mais longe decidiram desafiar as vossas
limites e as nossas crenças dos votos
medo de desafios vão mais longe e isto é
aquilo que eu estava aqui da minha
partilha e não sair do resto é bem
aquilo que entender é é acho que fomos
sobrecarregados com uma data de
informação como a data de exemplos
fantásticos eu gostei imenso estar aqui
ouvindo as partidas de todos os piscas
é um prazer e uma honra também pra mim
tá aqui assim é partilhar convosco e
gosto imenso partilhado compra um livro
gosto eu compro manhattan deus pode ser
os meus limites e o próprio desporto da
escola de paraquedismo que eu criei foi
isso também foi foi uma fantástica
enorme partilhar qualquer coisa me
apaixonava qualquer coisa pela qual não
dá um gozo enorme um e e pronto e
portanto isto quer dizer que o
consentimento para que as descobertas
entre os que eu tenho feito eu acho
o melhor foi esta foi foi foi lá tanta
coisa pra dizer mas é esta de vencer os
nossos medos vencer ultrapassará os
nossos mesmo não permitir um documento
fala mais alto
não permitiremos que a voz da minha avó
da cidade ou seja lá quem for condicione
aquilo que quer ser aquilo que eu posso
ser os meus objetivos kerchove dizer uma
coisa que espero que não levem a mal
esperto e bom é uma coisa eu digo sempre
a verdade
o palmeiras procura fazê lo e vou te
dizer uma coisa é que vocês não são tão
bons como pensam que são
são muito melhor e que eu explique que
seja o melhor
[Aplausos]
[Música]